prefacing all of this with partisanship
i've i've said it over and over i've
said it over and over uh
this is what i brought about brought up
about what vox was saying
everything right now is on track for joe
biden to be certified
inaugurated all that stuff these
lawsuits have not had any traction to
the point where we could say something
might change
as it stands now we we all kind of
expect it's going to be joe biden
that being said what if you know with
trump changing
uh just for just for for entertain the
conversation not like i think it's a you
know
it's a lottery ticket's chance if at all
what what happens if trump doesn't leave
and he's he gets rid of these you know
different heads of different departments
puts in loyalists
and then come you know the 14th or
whatever he says
no they'll be writing about it for a
thousand years
you'll have 77 million leftists or
whatever
saying trump is the dictator who's
trying to stage a coup
you'll have all the trump supporters
saying you know no trump is stopping
them from staging a coup
this is how it goes when there's a civil
war or a coup both sides accuse each
other of being the villain stealing the
power yes you need to dispel partisan
politics and good luck dude
that's the only way this is ridiculous
that people want to be in a tribe they
want to be a group that this was going
to happen
and they were writing the damn
constitution man factions
yeah really and george washington would
if he was
running for president as the democrat
right now he would say let's do the
right thing
let's look at the law and follow the law
well he gave up they want him to be king
and he said no right right no we need a
legitimate system
right i will sacrifice
some of these presidents very shortly
after were i think aaron burr was
accused of being
uh an honorless man who was in it only
for himself and his own ego
and that's part of what sparked the duel
between him and hamilton which
ultimately
killed hamilton was because he was
viewed as a narcissist who wanted power
how he's just talking about washington
you have to be you cannot become elected
president
unless you are a narcissist drunk i
don't think so
george washington was pretty unique he
might have been a narcissist it's the
first
one bro it's the first one yeah george
washington doesn't count because we just
we just finished this this revolutionary
war and they said how about you and he
was i don't want to be president well we
need somebody you're the
general fine dude dude my we put up in
my daughter's room a
list of all the presidents there's 45 of
them up there and around each of the
presidents is a color that represents
their political party
all the presidents have a politic have a
color on their frame
all of them except for one george
washington didn't have a party
you don't need one no there was there
was no
we don't need them anymore you can't you
can't keep referencing it's the first
one it's totally different a unique
circumstance that will never be lived
ever again
we're in a unique circumstance now with
the internet video
one guy can get a hundred million that's
not an argument what do you say you need
a political party
dude you have powerful special interests
and you have a machine with billions of
dollars you will not get on your own
all they can buy is influence even even
ross perot
he could only you know he did pretty
well the first time you know ross
it was he got built he got bill clinton
along and he was an old yeah not that
charismatic guy
george bush without the internet yeah if
it wasn't for
ross perot and then he ran again i think
at eight percent that was that was
impressive for an independent i mean he
wasn't
he was a billionaire wasn't teddy
roosevelt one is a third party i'm not
talking about a third party i'm talking
about no party you don't need a
political party
all right you just need a few a few
friends run with you you don't even need
that
dude trump took over and hijacked the
republican party because you need a
party to get elected and you need a
party
dude to govern of course
and this was trump's downfall is that he
didn't actually have
a party when he came to washington to
govern and he assumed the republicans
had his back
exactly so no there's no way you get in
there without having a political party
they did a personality man they did have
his back though you know they had a
knife in his back
yeah right they didn't have his back in
the way most people assume
no and that was i think man i re trump
was naive
he he went in thinking these guys okay i
won
i'm the president now you know i was in
this other day but i remember i was
outside of this building where trump was
meeting with gop leadership
and we knew back then in dc that it was
like a big deal that trump won and they
hated his guts
so he was going to meet with republican
leadership and they were going to talk
and i knew right then i'm like i know
what's happening trump got he's in it
escalade he pulls in
he sits down at the table you got a
bunch of republicans and they go okay
trump now here's how things works
and he goes no i'm the president here's
how things go
i'm telling you and they were like uh it
reminds me of
i don't know if you guys watched the new
rick and morty episode no not the latest
no
no not the latest one but the one where
it's the uh it's the the rick
uh the new city the citadel of ricks or
whatever oh no no i don't know
it's uh evil morty has the election and
wins and then he walks in and all the
ricks are laughing like you actually
think you're in charge because you were
elected
and then he goes how many of you think
this way raise your hand and then he
like snaps his finger and they shoot all
the unloyal guys
it reminds me kind of like that except
trump didn't you know kill a bunch of
people but trump
i'm assuming he walked in and they said
here's how things work
we're the party here's what we want you
to do and trump was like
no and he's still saying no because you
you have to imagine
like there was a story in the hill i
think i mentioned it where they said a
deal for trump to leave the white house
i'm sure he said no yeah i'm the
president
he's got a vision he wants to do
something he ran for a reason and he
means it
i think it's hilarious they tried
pushing off this narrative that trump
never wanted to win
when he filed the paperwork for maga in
2012 four years before he ran and then
he filed for reelection
the moment he got elected yeah he's been
intending to run for a long time
he's been talking about since the 90s i
think yeah and he had run
at least two times beforehand as well
yeah reform party though right
yeah which i had always thought were
just publicity stunts whatever whatever
which is kind of what i thought back
on the esk you know the escalator
incident i kind of thought oh this was
just a little bit of uh you know
publicity and he would just
kind of go back but this was the time
the wave was there
it wasn't right for him in the other
times you know like the world hadn't
gotten crazy enough things hadn't gotten
bad enough we hadn't
been fed up enough yet with the uniparty
to
decide like which one of these 17 guys
up here
is going to bust up the establishment
and then they pick trump to do it
kanye west could do it they didn't they
didn't have twitter before either really
not until 2010 and he hadn't done his tv
show
until when did the apprentice end when
did he leave the apprentice so
i don't know but we all watched the
apprentice everybody watched it super
famous person with social media
can get elected all right yeah but
through a party well he joined the party
he didn't
yeah he did no he didn't dude why do you
think bernie runs as a democrat dude
because he's an idiot
he should have run independent okay
uh i was thinking back sorry i was
saying you should have told hillary
take it suck it i'm going to run as an
independent as soon as it found out that
her
her server that they were trying to end
him and he would have won no it would
have split the demo he would have
dominated that election 40 percent of
democrats identify as progressive as of
2018
so that many of them would have defected
many of them would say i don't want to
risk trump winning
but it would split the vote for sure
yeah all the people
half the trump's voters would have voted
for him the democrats are fractured and
the republicans are unified
indeed on that that is for sure which is
which is republicans are shattered with
trump's their [ __ ]
their freaking head man no and they've
got mitch mcconnell in the party
i'm i'm citing pew and economist data
that shows yes
the republican party has coalesced
around a core central ideal
ideals he's talking about the people the
people of the party
not the president the president and the
party apparatus are not aligned
but the voters and the president clearly
are yes oh
i see on the democrat side it's split
into two mounds of progress yeah that's
for sure
so if you if you break those up and
they're literally two different parties
they seriously are you've got union
working-class corporate weird
amalgam it's like joe biden represents
that i'll say whatever i have to say to
convince people to vote for me
then you have progressives who are like
socialism
all the way literally and i guess they
try to deny it but it's ridiculous
they don't agree you you like the the
joe biden's a capitalist he loves going
and making all that sweet money through
his name and his family names and his
kid out to make cash for him and his
brother
yeah but if you're a communist you can
make even for your money off your sweet
name
and if you're a communist you can call
yourself a democrat and run as a
democratic nominee well so here's here's
the big problem i see it
joe biden doesn't represent anybody as
far as i'm concerned right like
nobody wanted joe biden you know what i
mean like exactly
exactly settle for biden so here's what
i here's what i see
most liberals traditional liberals are
not
active they're not paying attention and
they're well i should say these are
passive liberals
these are people who probably have
similar uh policy visions to to us to
all of us actually
and they're not paying attention so you
have very very politically active
progressives that dominate the narrative
over and over again
you then have your only option outside
of them to not be a conservative is like
the likes of
chuck schumer and nancy pelosi and
they're awful old crony corporate
establishment politicians
there is no moderate liberal populist
you either have trump which is right
populism and then you have bernie who
joined the ranks of the corporate
democrats i guess but
my choice right now what do i have do i
vote for this for the for the lunatic
socialist
woke people no but then i'm like i'm not
going to vote for
biden why is i gotta vote for trump no
here's the choice that people made and i
was thinking about this back when you
mentioned like
how is it that biden got more votes than
barack obama
right back in what 2008 so 12 years
later
is are the demographic changes so
profound that we're going to turn out
that many people no
more people turn out for joe biden than
to turn out for the
you know the first black president of
the united states he was a celebrity
dude
he was he was barack obama was assaulted
that's what i'm saying that's what i'm
saying
let me let me get to the point here so
the point actually is that the choice
that the democrats were faced with was
this
do i want to be mentally tortured for
another four years by my
own party the democratic party and the
democratic media have
tortured gaslit and abused
the democratic voter for four years by
telling them that this guy donald trump
who everybody loved in 2014
who was on the apprentice and with oprah
and with jesse jackson and getting
awards from naacp and the whole thing
and we're going to say all of a sudden
he's a racist he's hitler he's the end
of the world he's authoritarian
you should be scared you should be
terrified you should be
freaking out the democratic party
beat their own voters into voting for
whomever they decided the only choice
the democrats had was
please make it stop and they didn't know
they don't know what it is
but really they're just saying please
make it stop and where's the abuse
coming from
it's not coming from trump's policies
it's not coming from the actions of the
republican party
it's not coming from maga patriots
blowing up cities and rioting all over
the place no
the torture is coming from the democrats
they're doing it to their own
people with their foot soldiers in the
street with black lives matter and
antifa
and all this chaos and saying to people
if you don't vote
for our guy you're gonna let hitler take
over the country and they're just like
please
make it stop they're all deranged and
broken down
on purpose that's the only choice and
where are we at now
the media is saying the election's over
joe biden one submit
submit even though we haven't gone
through state certification
let alone choosing electors let alone
certifying the electoral results
congress has to then certify the results
after that we've gone through none of
the traditional constitutional processes
and they're already saying
shut your mouth joe biden is the
president
a lot about corporate media political
collusion on this
just in life in general on the show do
you think they were incrementally
moving towards a better place a solution
where that kind of thing isn't happening
no dude power's being concentrated
countries being polarized networks are
being fortified and hardened
and our separations are going beyond
political movements and now into tribes
and it's all being fueled by money and
corporate sponsors and curators and
influencers and the media and everybody
pushing us into these horribly
ostracized tribes
based on empathetic triggers that make
us want to hate each other
no it's not getting anything who's doing
it it's
an emergent phenomenon it's there's not
one
old guy you know pulling all the
marionette strings yeah
it's an emergent phenomenon i'm sure
soros has done stuff the honest
part of the emergency you see right he's
part of it it's this all of the
billionaires
they all have an alignment currently and
it's playing out they want to diminish
the power of the federal government i
know people aren't talking about that as
much the democrats don't touch the
corporations they don't do anything with
antitrust
blm antifa want to see the government
diminish the socialists want to see gov
like a revolution well they disagree
they want the power of the government
for themselves right right exactly
yeah they well they want to change the
way that we're doing things right the
critical race theorists want to just
deconstruct the entire apparatus that's
existing and so all of them have the
same common interest which is diminish
the power of the federal government
and that's why they're all on the same
team right now you know i i i disagree
though
i like the idea of diminishing federal
government authority or taking their
power sure but they're doing it to exert
their own power over us corporate power
racism
power all that fear i'm trying to vamp
around no i see that myself
infiltrating these institutions and
government for power
i feel like you look at the media the
military and you look at the new york
times the new york mag just wrote this
big piece about how there's a ton of
people in new york times
like worried that it's become a woke
activist brigade
you have enough people of this new
religion you know
intersectionality where they can stage a
coup
internally at these companies because i
think like you mentioned most people are
like i don't know i just you know just
leave me out of it i guess
yeah no it's already happened the coup
is already happening it happened through
hr departments
is it the is it the is it the the
vatican
through the british government trying to
retake the american people back like
they're trying to
what are you doing we separated from the
british crown in 1776
and there's a lot of british crown money
in the vatican and are they trying to
take the united states
you just is it the british hey i'm
allowed to say that the united states
said goodbye british crown and we
revolted against them what does
they have to do are they trying to take
the united states back no are you sure
i'm just i'm just grabbing it straws
that literally who are these people
nothing
is this emergent why is this emergence
happening to the united states
government
because there are people who are in the
united states who have gotten jobs
in these in these departments who have
an ideology and want to exert it and
they're aligned with their it's not
just people in the united states global
corporations are doing this
they're doing it because the u.s has
money and they're seeing what people are
posting on social media
twitter has created a machine that
incentivizes people to cancel you
because they can put their paper but the
us doesn't have money the us borrows
money from a federal bank
federal reserve federal bank from a
price you are literally saying randomly
i'm
wondering why is this emergence trying
to take hold of the
american government right now it's
international wokism is everywhere
corporations are everywhere it's just a
matter in some of those countries the
general population is along for the ride
in the united states we are not we're
not like that when i say diminish
government power in this alliance there
are some people that want to seize
control of the government right
for their own ends whether and then it's
like exerting the government influence
to their benefit
but then there's other people that want
to seize control the government so that
the government doesn't do anything
yeah so that they can just keep doing
what they're doing the corporations can
run around unmolested right the america
so it's either they're trying to take a
hold of the u.s military
or they're trying to destroy the us
constitution well they are trying to
destroy the constitution that's for sure
and why
is this international corporation
trying to destroy the u.s constitution
what are you talking about
no destroying the us constitution is
just like a byproduct of the fact that
they want although they've said they
want to keep their power
they've said get rid of the constitution
there's a new republic article saying
the left should actively campaign
against the written constitution of the
united states
sure that would be and it's because they
want to ban speech
and it's because they want to maintain
power and if you can't share ideas those
ideas can't persist you know
i'm sorry for bringing up the british
crown i just think
the power structure of a monarchy
bothers me and i wonder if this
corporate thing is
is similar to that no and they want to
destroy this freedom mechanism of the
u.s constitution so that they can exert
top-down authority that not none of
sometimes that real
crudely to you real mean with with it
has nothing to do with
emergence in any way emergence is a
person goes on twitter
and says uh jack murphy is alt-right
he gets a million retweets and then he
goes send me money through paypal
and he realizes wow if i call people all
right i can put my paypal link and get
money
then a bunch of people start realizing
they can do this so they all start doing
at the same time
then coca-cola goes on a twitter and
goes whoa they really like it when you
call people all right
coca-cola we don't like the alt-right
either they're targeting what the
you know the big corporations are
putting money behind what they see and
what they think
you've got democrats that are doing the
same thing a democratic politician comes
on and says wow a lot of people are
talking about the alt-right i oppose
them vote for me
now all of a sudden you've built this
twisted weird culture
around nonsensical cancel culture and
woke ideas because on twitter it made
people money
then 92 percent of the population who
don't prescribe to these beliefs are
like
what i'm not voting for that guy and
then the republicans
are on track to win what like 12 seats
in the house now
because they're like this is ridiculous
and makes no sense
the crazy thing about it though is it
started to go into the hr departments
and now regular people who are like i
don't care about twitter and cancel
culture
walk into their workplace one day and
someone says oh
you're not checking your privilege and
they're like wait a minute
what is this now i think
or when you see it in your children's
curriculum
at school forcing your kids to have
courageous conversations and sit in
their witness
or when they uh your kids come home and
call you racist
exactly yeah thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you